اطول معركه في عمر الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا انتهت بالسيطره على بخمه تماما
لتستعد قوات فاجنر لتسليمها الى القوات
الروسيه وان انتهت المعركه الرئيسيه فصراع
السيطره على المدينه لم ينتهي فقد اكد
قائد القوات الاوكرانيه
واصمت عار بحق روسيا هكذا وصف قائد قوات
فاجنرز استعاده القوات الاوكرانيه لبلده
برخيفكا شمال باخموت والتي كان الكرملين
اعلن السيطره الكامله عليها في العشرين من
مايو الماضي ايضا زعيم الانفصاليين في
دونيتسكي يقول ان الوضع في باخمت اصبح
اكثر صعوبه كما استمرت الاشتباكات حول
ضخمه بالرغم من تراجع نسبي في حده القتال
بحسب القوات الاوكرانيه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات